one of the things you actually have to
do if you really want to understand the
way that stars work is understand what
kind of stars there are and how many of
different types there are and so on
because if you're going to come up with
a theory of how stars form and evolve
it's got to match onto those
observations so you've got to do this
sort of fairly pedestrian activity of
actually just classifying the stars so
the the sun for example is has its own
classification and the various different
classification schemes that have been
used but the one that's in most common
use nowadays called the mk system is
that the sun is classified as a g2v star
stars are completely different they
range in size in the amount of stuff
they have and the amount of density in
what type of stuff they have if it's
carbon or oxygen and they vary in
temperature the real problem in
classification is that generally the
classification gets done before you
understand what it is you're classifying
that means that very often in astronomy
you end up with a classification scheme
which physically doesn't make a lot of
sense because you just classify it on
some fairly arbitrary basis at the time
it's sort of a historical nightmare as
to how stars are classified
they were originally just you look at
them and depending on how bright they
are you give them a number so the
brightest ones were one and then they
went fainter to about five or six and
then it got a bit more techno
technological when we were able to look
at a spectrum of a star so if you shine
the light of a star through a prism and
you look at its rainbow you can see
different different characteristics of a
star in particular hydrogen
and so a very sensible what seemed a
sensible classification scheme at the
science time was to classify all the
spectra according to the strength of
their hydrogen lines and various other
lines as well but mainly the hydrogen
lines and what they did is they had
basically an alphabetical sequence
starting at a working way through the
alphabet where a stars were the ones
that had the strongest hydrogen lines
and so on bcd and so on down through the
classification scheme as the hydrogen
lines got weaker and weaker and other
lines got stronger so about the
mid-1800s is when this first started
happening it turns out that actually
physically this isn't a very sensible
way of classifying things because it's
actually it's a it's a goldilocks and
the three bears problem and finally
annie jump cannon one of the first women
who actually did astronomy um or is
remembered for doing astronomy
she was the one who who got very
specific in the classifications of these
stars when the way you get strong
hydrogen lines in the atmosphere of a
star is that you the star you know is
hot enough to kind of excite the
hydrogen and then the
the hydrogen then is there to kind of
absorb some of the starlight
and um
if a star is too hot then the hydrogen
all just gets ripped apart it actually
gets ionized so the protons and the
electrons that make up the hydrogen get
ripped apart and there isn't any
hydrogen there isn't any unionized
hydrogen in the atmosphere so you don't
see any of these absorption lines
if the star's too cold then the atoms
are all in their ground state in other
words the hydrogen atoms just never get
excited at all they never do anything so
they just sit there they don't actually
absorb any light it's only a temperature
somewhere in the middle where actually
hydrogen lines get excited and you end
up with these very strong hydrogen ions
so that's why hydrogen you know the the
stars that have these strong hydrogen
lines are somewhere at intermediate
temperatures they're not too hot and
they're not too cold
she kind of did away with the the a
through whatever letter it was because
she realized there were characteristics
that weren't just
noticeable in the spectrum but related
to physical properties of the star you
can use the same letters but you just
need to rearrange them so that they're
in temperature order rather than any
other order so instead of being a b c d
the order in which these stars come is o
b a f g k m so it ends up being o b a f
g k m and she just got rid of all the
ones that kind of repeated their
properties and that's not particularly
memorable collection of letters but it's
been and the reason why i could just
rattle it off like that is because it's
remembered by generations of astronomers
by a mnemonic a way of a little sentence
remembering it uh obvious fine girl uh
kiss me is the traditional way of doing
it but there's other ones that people
have come up with as well oh be a fine
guy kiss me
and i think there's a few other ones you
can say it'll be a fine girl kiss me if
that's your liking oh be a fine girl or
guy depending on your preferences kiss
me
and so i oh be a fine girl kiss me ob
afg km is the order in which these
things are and that's then ordered from
the hottest stars which are the o stars
down to the coolest stars which are the
m stars the temperature basically
determines a lot about what's going on
with the star and the temperature is
correlated very closely with its mass
so more massive stars have generally
hotter temperatures in their atmospheres
and lower mass stars have cooler
temperatures and mass temperature
has a lot to do with how long a star
lives how bright it's going to be
what kind of star it'll end up in
eventually either a white dwarf or a
black hole why didn't they just change
all the letters on the stars why did
they keep the old letters it's because
you get stuck right you you have a
classification scheme and there's a
whole bunch so there was a huge
catalogue for example
produced in the 19th century of hundreds
of thousands of stars that had all been
classified by this scheme
and so rather than going through and
reclassifying all the stars the easiest
thing to do is just to remember a
mnemonic for the right order to remember
the letters in rather than going back to
hundreds of thousands of spectra and
reclassifying everything
the sun is sort of a typical star in the
sense that it's in the middle of the uh
obj km system to g star and its official
classification is a g2 v let's start at
the uh at the back end of it the v is
actually a roman numeral five
and all stars are classified according
to their luminosity with luminosity
class one things being the brightest all
the way down to luminosity class five
and actually this luminosity class six
which is a little fainter and
occasionally white dwarf stars which are
even fainter are called luminosity class
seven so the v at the end is just
telling you how bright the star is
then the other bit of it is telling you
about it's effectively about its
temperature g is actually it tells you
that it's a it's actually somewhere in
the middle of the classification scheme
so the sun is not the not the hottest
star not the coolest star somewhere in
the middle once you have a
classification of a g star you can even
classify it further and say it's a g0 or
g1 or g9 so g0s are the hottest and g9
are the coolest so among g stars the sun
is
towards the hotter end so it's a g2 but
yeah it's just a typical star it's uh
it's right in the middle temperature
range right in the middle of the mass
range
um it's it's not the most common type of
star because the m and k stars are much
more common but it's a typical star in a
sense that it just sort of straddles all
the
possible ranges that we know of stars
the neat thing comes when you actually
start looking at collections of stars so
instead of looking at the properties of
individual stars you start looking at
collections of them so the first people
to do this were a couple of astronomers
called hertzberg and russell so there's
a very famous diagram named after them
so this is a very well-known chart it's
called the hertzberg russell diagram
named after the two people
that used it um
so we have
going this way brightness so brighter
stars are at the top and we have on this
axis temperature
and it's a bit backwards so stars get
hotter as you go this way you can see at
the bottom they have the classification
the o b a
and you see this nice diagonal line here
this is what's called the main sequence
so most stars spend most of their life
on the main sequence and this is
where they are while they're burning
hydrogen while they're fusing new
chemical elements in their cores and
then after some amount of time and for
our sun it's about 10 billion years
we're already halfway through that so we
have 5 billion more
the
the star will evolve off the main
sequence and become a red giant so for
example the sun in its distant future is
going to turn into a red giant star so
it'll cease being a v star a
low luminosity star main sequence star
and will become a giant star so it'll be
a luminosity class one or two and it
will actually get cooler as it does so
it'll turn into a redder star so it'll
move down the sequence so it'll stop
being a g star and probably become a k
star or even an m star